boy and it's a team that's going to
grind him out similar to the other two
teams he's faced now in his major league
career
very patient at the plate he's going to
have to establish that strike zone
certainly with that fastball we'll see
if that slider is in play here today and
that is something we've seen i've seen
glimpses of it and that's really good
inconsistency
but this is going to be another
challenge for the youngster here today
altuve pushes it demers off the bounds
spins and fires and hits
[Applause]
he is out and that's a great call by
mark rutger behind the play because
altuve what's inside the field of play
and it caught his arm well that's
sometimes a spark like that a break like
that for a young pitcher like reed
detmers maybe that gets him going today
a break going his way michael brantley
now he hits very well on the road and he
rolls that slowly up the middle
fletcher onto first
he's going to slide again a quick ground
ball a soft contact ground ball
carlos correa gets a warm welcome and
here's the o2 and that one there chase
the miss good curveball struck him out
well that right there probably the best
inning in his young major league career
sets him down in a hurry limited number
of hitches
and your road starter to close out this
series is lance mccullers jr great
numbers on the season a 3-2-2 era
that whip at 1.26 and 128 strikeouts in
those 19 starts so far the opponent
average
205 and mostly because he's held
right-handed hitters to a 176 batting
average this season tony last night
homer single stole a base
jam shot way off the bag as guriel flips
but colors did he hit the bag
he's off the bag he's safe the colors in
leaping for that throw over shot the
runway especially you know with that
speed of shohei ohtani coming down the
line misses the bag
trying to get the heel unable to do so
show hey otani on the base right now
beating out that ground ball unable to
get to the bag and delivers
ground ball softly hit right side to his
left altuve he has it throws to first
that's his only play and fletcher is
retired
for the first out of the inning as
ohtani goes to second facing the lefty
here jared walsh
swinging a miss and got it there's two
away good arm side run and then you add
the 96 miles an hour to it it makes it
very tough to catch up to when it's
up and away from a left-handed hitter so
two out and ohtani still at second for
phil goslin seeing his first activity in
this series what colors delivers
swinging in a mess got him with the
slider stayed with that pitch and gets
gosselin to win the inning back-to-back
strikeouts from the colors
works around the lead off hit by 09.
jazz mccormick stands in
hammer to left field is jack mayfield
unable to make the play and there is a
base hit that's the first hit of the day
for the astros and now the astros with
two on it two outs cormac got a high
curveball it was really high a hangar
and he was able to hit that past the
shortstop so here's myers boy what a
night he had last night in the second
big league start a couple of homers
including a grand slam drove in five
runs 3-2 and after all that a curveball
gets them swinging that is how the
inning will end gophers gets
strikeout number two today and the
astros will leave a pair of runners on
base brandon marsh playing in his 28th
game
swinging a miss and he struck him out
third strikeout of the day for lance
mccullars jr he struck out three of the
last four angels he's faced so opt-in at
second adele at first with one out for
kurt suzuki the catcher colors with the
o2 to suzuki swing and a mess got him on
the slider away and mccullers gets his
fourth strikeout each of his last four
outs have been punch outs two away
good hard slider running away from the
right-handed batter the bases are loaded
and joe hey otani will be the batter
two-strike pitch swing and a mess good
morning good afternoon and good night
shohei ohtani three straight curve balls
and the cullers works out of the bases
loaded jam brantley grounded out as last
time up that is crushed to right field
see you later baseball michael brantley
leaving the yard his eighth home run of
the season a no doubter uncle mike
making detmer's pay for leaving a pitch
up out over the plate uncle mike
professional hitter power hitter and
this hit bad 107.6 off the bat near
rydish there was no doubt about this
slider breaks in right over the middle
part of the plate performing trots to
first alvarez pushed to second and here
comes myers
and he got it in there good hard slider
lowing in gets myers
really tied him up on that last one
ohtani 2 for 12 in his career against
lance mccullers jr here's the next
delivery and that's a shot right up the
middle that's going to be a base hit
it's going to roll into center field
mayfield's going to go first the third
throw to third is late joe hayes moving
up the second they didn't have anybody
there to cover the bag initially and he
gets there safely and the angels have
something brewing here a hit could mean
two runs here and give the angels the
lead a hit would certainly
at least tie it fletcher a little ground
ball that will score one where tony's
going to get to third the pit of first
is in time and the game is tied here's a
2-2 to walsh
that is strike three call on the outside
corner frozen with the hook inning over
angels tie it on the fletcher rbi ground
out they're not going to make a pitching
change here they're talking over joe
adele who will be batting with runners
at first and third one out in a 1-1 game
adele up the middle
altuve has one no way to get it down
and the angels lead the game
2-1 that'll be the end of the day for
lance mccullers through 108 pitches
through five and two-thirds
bradley not a stolen-based threat
quintana
against correa on the ground gosling
fletcher
yes
double play the 12th correa has rolled
into this year goose
playing some defense five four three
double play huge there's jordan
gordon hits a bullet down the right
field line that'll be extra bases as he
turns first headed for second joe adele
will get it in and jordan will hold up
with a
stand-up two-base hit with two outs
here's the 1-1
and he lifts this one in the air it's
not very deep though it should be an out
under waiting making the catch on that
one is justin upton and the routine fly
ball to the angels left fielder will
wrap up the inning one out no one on for
phil gosselin he doubled and scored in
the sixth
home run number four of the season that
one dropped in the angels bullpen out
there
and the angels get an add-on run and now
lead it 3-1
castro now pitch hits
castro ground ball diving walsh can't
get it it goes in the right on his way
to third goes diaz castro will go to
second and the astros have the tying
runs in scoring position with two out of
the ninth second and third and here
comes altuve 2-2
and the angels win it iglesias ends up
striking out the side the angels come
away with the victory here today when
it's three to one